hey friends welcome back to deep dive
snippets this is a clip that you're
about to hear from oliver berkman the
author of 4000 weeks time and how to use
it and it relates to the idea of goal
setting now if you've seen videos on my
main channel link to the video
description you'll know i i have a bit
of a bit of a weird relationship with
the idea of goals in that part of me
things are a bit pointless and part of
me things that kind of useful anyway
here is what author and fellow
productivity guru oliver bergman has to
say on the topic of goals i hope you
find it interesting on the goal setting
front um i i also keep on trying to find
the perfect system for this like
um in in terms of like like like
personal goals one of my theories
my philosophies shall we say
is that setting like i don't like it
when i set goals that are outside of my
control for example
when
i set the goal of i want a youtube video
that hits a certain view count right
compared to i want to make a video i'm
proud of when i think i want to write a
book that hits this under times my set
list versus i want to write a book i'm
proud of and that's all fine but that
almost feels like it's oh well i'll just
do my best and not worry about the
outcome which also which feels a little
bit unsatisfying
given
a bunch of research around the idea of
like effective goal setting and
challenging goal setting and the fact
that kind of high performance inverted
commas in most fields you know it's not
like michael phelps is just you know
what i'll just try my best and see what
happens
right right yeah so yeah any any
thoughts around that tension between
i'll try my best versus i have this
specific outcome i'm aiming for which
may be someone outside of my control
it's interesting i mean i there's a sort
of sub distinction there between there's
the goal there's the things you can
control and things you can't control but
then there's
specificity or vagueness
in the things that you can
control and i i do think that like
things like doing your best and
being proud of things like they're
really important values in life but i
can see how they're not they're not
particularly helpful in this setting
because it's sort of completely
open-ended and so it's not very smart i
know right exactly either you
can either you will end up sort of not
doing what you could have done because
you say well that was my best so i don't
care like and you sort of you sort of
make it easy for yourself or you do what
i think i would do and have done in a
lot of my early adulthood which is like
be convinced that trying your best is
really important and then like torment
yourself constantly with like am i doing
my best is this my best am i can i you
know and those kind of open-ended things
seem unhelpful you on the other hand if
you say i mean this is where i feel like
quantity-based goals can be really
helpful right if you say like i'm going
to put out this number of videos or this
number of i'm going to write
this many words uh
on a by a certain point firstly it's
specific
secondly it's within your control and
then thirdly it's kind of
it's somewhat drained of the sort of the
quality of goals are sort of
they they go wrong because they're so
sort of emotive there's something kind
of nice about a very very sort of
mechanistic
goals in that area and i think it's the
whole piece of the puzzle because i do
think even though i wrote in my first
book about like
how positive visualization is largely
nonsense and all sorts of things i do
think there's clearly a role for kind of
envisioning the having a vision of where
you'd like things to be and using it to
to determine what you do in the in the
present but that idea of just being
maybe this is like systems versus goals
that it's that old distinction but it's
like it's like the idea of saying like
this many words
um
or you know just something really sort
of
that sort of takes out all the
all the all the angst from it i think
that's gonna be really useful yeah well
one of the ways i'm thinking about it
because i'm i'm i was writing the
chapter about this in the book like this
week last week um
i intended to do this week as well but
then time goes away like like
um
is yeah like systems
i feel like all
all of this stuff converges on a few
central central themes and
we as productivity writers try to put
our own stamp on like a thing which
people have been doing for centuries not
millennia but that aside um
what i'm what i really like is is that
if i kind of break down my implicit
process of goal setting because it's
never been like explicit if i if i break
down what that looked like what it
looked like was step number one
setting a kind of destination goal that
is within my control like write a book
i'm proud of which is like this big
product big project
um maybe in my mind it's like it would
be really cool if it hits the best
sellers it would be really cool if i get
invited on conferences and if i i don't
know get on a podcast because that that
would be sick but like those are outside
of my control so let me just
not think about those yeah and just
recognize that actually it's a you know
a preferred indifferent as as as the
stomachs might might say right um so the
the destination goal is within my
control and then i'll break that down
into the kind of journey goals which are
is more the system stuff
therefore what i like tangibly need to
do is that every week or every day i
want to aim to write x thousand words or
x hundred words
and again that is within my control
and then kind of my step three of this
three-step process is
for that journey goal that like let's
say i want to write 500 words a day to
lower the bar of quality as much as
possible
yeah i want like i literally write my
to-do list write 500 crappy words for
crappy first draft of chapter two and i
find that putting the words crappy in
there twice
really makes it easier to be okay you
know what this is actually it's actually
doable
great it makes me think of two other
things like um dan harris the meditation
writer and the podcaster um
talks about doing things specifically
meditation uh aiming to do them
daily-ish
and having like having this built-in
built-in fuzziness like because you know
whether you did something dailyish like
in a given week you you have a feel like
if you did it twice it wasn't dalish but
it but it reduces this kind of like oh
if i break my streak it's all over and i
might as well spend the next three weeks
not doing anything
um so i think that's a that's an
important part of that and then
something i found really helpful i don't
know
if this is writing specific but like
might be just specific to writing but
it's also like not keeping going even if
you're on a roll so if you say like i'm
going to write 500 words and you write
them and then things are going well like
i get another 500 out it's like actually
making yourself stop and walk away like
that kind of enforced low balling of
your of your aims for the day and like
that's really i think for people like i
suspect you and certainly for me like
that's really hard to do yeah like when
the opportunity for a bit more
productivity arises and you don't take
it yes but there's this amazing old book
that i had to like buy as print on
demand because it's because it's so hard
to get called um how writer's journey to
comfort and fluency by a psychologist
called robert boyce and it's like a
really in-depth study of academic
writers and what caused them to
be either productive or non-not
productive um i mentioned him in the
book a couple of times and like one of
his big findings was that the writers
who made writing into a
a moderately important part of their
lives were did lots more than the ones
who made it into a very important part
of their lives because then it becomes
this kind of intimidating thing and you
have sort of all sorts of angst about it
and you forget about it for weeks at a
time because you don't dare go back into
that scary thing and part of that is
like you figure out what is your short
daily session of writing
and he said like you know
for people sort of amateur writers i
might be 10 minutes a day even for
professional writers it probably should
never be more than like three or four
hours and when it's up you just you have
to stop and like go and do something
else because otherwise you're kind of
giving in to a
an impatient urge to be done with the
whole thing that will ultimately
backfire on you and cause you to sort of
dread yeah returning to the project that
ability to keep important things
relatively small in your life i think
it's like it's really i'm not saying i'm
really good at it yeah but it's it's
really interesting hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day